[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie
[Applauso]
chi da piccolo non ho mai sognato di
volare anche una volta
Beh io l'ho segnato tantissime volte
pure nonostante i mille tentativi che ho
fatto di saltare quanto più in alto
possibile ovviamente non ci sono mai
riuscito
la casa dei nonni dove passavo le mie
estate era in campagna ed era
precisamente lungo la rotta di
atterraggio per i voli da Londra ed io
passavo ore ed ore della mia giornata a
guardare questi enormi oggetti volare
senza mai spiegarmi come facessero
oggetti Appunto così grandi a stare in
equilibrio nell'area mentre io che ero
sicuramente più piccolo e più leggero
non ce la facessi
Io sono del 2000 e nell'estate del 2004
a 4 anni ho costretto mio nonno ad
insegnarmi e andare in bici impara in un
giorno avevo visto mia sorella che è più
grande di me che andava in bici senza
quelle routine che si utilizzano per
dare stabilità ai bambini ed io curioso
e competitivo come sono non potevo
assolutamente esimermi dal provarci
quel giorno che ha di 50 volte 60 volte
ho passato tutta la mattina e tutto il
pomeriggio a cadere Finché poi tardo
pomeriggio verso sera riuscì a fare
qualche pedalata a stare in equilibrio e
ancora mi ricordo la reazione di mamma e
papà Erano ovviamente contenti del fatto
che io fossi riuscito ad imparare Questa
nuova cosa Però d'altro canto immaginate
mia madre che si ritrova in piena estate
con un bambino di 4 anni pieno di tagli
graffi lividi e così via che deve essere
medicato e io come vedete qua Ero già un
po' più grande ma io volevo solamente
andare in bici tutto il giorno
però voi giustamente vi chiederete Ma
cosa c'entra l'aereo con la bici con il
tema di oggi che è l'equilibrio
Allora io vorrei porvi un ulteriore
domanda
Avete mai pensato come fa un aereo a
volare
l'aereo è un oggetto enorme pesa 3000 kg
vuoto 60.000 kg a pieno carico
e per volare deve rompere l'equilibrio
delle forze che lo tengono attaccato al
suolo costruirne uno nuovo e mantenerlo
Mi spiego meglio quando l'aereo è in
volo con le sue ali incontra un flusso
d'aria Ovviamente questo flusso d'aria
viene diviso in due l'aria che va sopra
le ali si muove più velocemente quindi è
meno pressione mentre quella che passa
sotto si muove più lentamente Quindi è
più pressione e questo particolare
fenomeno genera una forza aerodinamica
che si chiama portanza che esiste
solamente grazie al movimento dell'aereo
e alla portanza che lo tiene in volo
Quindi ricapitolando l'aereo è un
oggetto enorme che pesa tantissimo
che per volare deve rompere un
equilibrio costruire uno nuovo e
mantenere lo solamente grazie al suo
spostamento
la bici sotto alcuni punti di vista
segue un principio simile Noi siamo in
equilibrio perché pedalando facciamo
girare le ruote e girando le ruote si
genera un effetto giroscopico che ci
permette di battere la forza di gravità
non cadiamo a destra e neanche a
sinistra
Riuscite a vedere che c'è un elemento in
comune tra i due
Entrambe le cose hanno bisogno di
muoversi per stare in equilibrio
Io sono uno studente al quarto anno di
università
ho 19 lavoro da quando a 19 anni e da
due anni a questa parte sono impegnato
nella mia startup perché sì sono uno di
quei pazzi che ha vent'anni oltre a
studiare prova a lanciare un suo
progetto un suo progetto senza
esperienza senza competenze poi sembrerà
strano ma oltre a studiare e lavorare Ho
anche degli amici una fidanzata faccio
sport esco fuori a cena Faccio più o
meno tutto quello che fanno i ragazzi di
20 anni come me
Però sarebbe tremendamente facile oggi
raccontarvi che io sono il superuomo
dannunziano che ha trovato il suo
equilibrio che sa stare in equilibrio
che sa gestirsi tra impegni scadenze
problemi soluzioni
ma non è così
molto molto spesso vado anch'io leggevo
una ricerca che diceva che il
78,5% degli studenti universitari
italiani almeno una volta nella vita ha
sperimentato Cosa significa soffrire di
un disturbo psicologico
Ed io sinceramente faccio parte di
questi
la mia carriera universitaria inizia nel
2019 faccio le valigie e parto per Roma
io vengo da una piccola realtà in Umbria
e ero convinto di arrivare nella città
dei balocchi da me ci conosciamo tutti
siamo tutti amici conoscenti e tutto ha
portato ad uomo e dal giorno alla notte
mi ritrovo
catapultato in una realtà enorme Un
oceano di persone una marea di stimoli
nessun amico qualche conoscente tutto
completamente nuovo
e per me le prime settimane sono
veramente molto complessi io ero
abituato che se c'era qualche problema
tornavo a casa ne parlavo con i genitori
e in qualche modo Una soluzione si
trovava ma ora non potevo ero qua a Roma
da solo
e
Io in quel momento non capivo che stavo
facendo quello che fa l'aereo quando si
stacca dal suolo io stavo rompendo il
mio vecchio equilibrio e ne stavo
costruendo uno nuovo però vi ricordate
c'è un elemento fondamentale per far sì
che l'aereo possa volare c'è bisogno di
muoversi di stare in movimento a me
mancava proprio quello io ero fermo
immobile sopra le mie orme e aspettavo
che fosse il mondo a roteare a muoversi
non io a fare un passo Allora ho
iniziato ad apprezzare Veramente questo
percorso universitario nel momento in
cui ho capito che ero io a dovermi
muovere non posso fare nuove amicizie se
non sono io ad interagire con qualcuno
non posso conoscere un nuovo professore
che magari ha per me consigli stimoli
idee suggerimenti se non sono io ad
alzare la mano oppure ad avvicinarmi la
cattedra a fine lezione Non posso
sicuramente trovare una nuova
opportunità se non sono io a cercarla
ecco
Se noi vogliamo stare in equilibrio
dobbiamo saperci muovere mentre se
vogliamo fare un passo in avanti uno
step in più nella nostra vita dobbiamo
essere disposti a rompere l'equilibrio
che abbiamo e a costruirne uno nuovo e
la vera difficoltà sta nel fatto che
spesso le due cose coincidono avvengono
insieme
Allora ho iniziato ad elaborare una mia
teoria a riguardo Sono partito da questo
schema che ho letto nel libro Le sette
regole per avere successo
nella parte esterna troviamo appunto il
contesto esterno il contesto esterno
contiene tutto ciò che ci cade addosso
su cui non abbiamo controllo non abbiamo
influenze non abbiamo nulla ci cade
addosso Lo subiamo e basta un po' più
internamente troviamo la zona di
influenza appunto nella zona di
influenza c'è tutto ciò che noi possiamo
influenzare con ciò che facciamo non
possiamo controllare né gestire Però
possiamo influenzarlo
nella parte centrale Infine abbiamo la
zona di controllo quella zona in cui noi
siamo nel pieno controllo di ciò che
succede con la zona in cui sappiamo che
facendo A otteniamo B perché
controlliamo quello che accade Allora io
ho preso e l'ho cambiata i nomi la zona
di controllo è diventata la zona di
equilibrio Noi siamo in equilibrio
quando facciamo le cose che sappiamo
controllare
quando facciamo quello che facciamo
tutti i giorni
appena fuori dalla zona di equilibrio
c'è la zona di movimento Noi siamo in
movimento quando proviamo a fare un
passo in più facendo un passo in più ci
muoviamo studiamo una nuova materia
proviamo un nuovo metodo di studio ci
lanciamo in un nuovo progetto
e la cosa veramente bellissima è che la
zona di movimento è allenabile possiamo
allenarla e farla crescere la zona di
equilibrio cresce se cresce quella di
movimento e la zona di movimento
allenandosi a muoverci riusciamo a farla
crescere
come vediamo la zona di movimento grazie
alla sospensione ha iniziato a prendere
anche parte di quel contesto esterno che
prima ci cadeva addosso adesso non più
possiamo fare qualcosa per influenzare
quello che succede e la diretta
conseguenza di questo è che se cresce la
zona di movimento cresce anche quella di
equilibrio
Ecco la zona di equilibrio
non è ferma immobile
ma cresce se la alimentiamo E decresce
se non le diamo da mangiare attraverso
il movimento è proprio questo il punto
per me
è proprio questo Io non ho mai smesso di
reiterare questo processo
però prima ho detto che sarà stato
sincero con voi Quindi voglio mantenere
questa promessa io per cercare il mio
equilibrio l'ho perso un milione di
volte e un milione di volte lo perderò è
normale
è normale perché muovendoci è normale
che incontriamo strade impervie
piuttosto che andiamo troppo forte
oppure troppo piano in ogni caso cadiamo
Io penso che per apprezzare totalmente
l'equilibrio dobbiamo apprezzare
totalmente il fallimento io vengo da una
piccola famiglia di imprenditori e sono
cresciuto con questa frase solamente chi
fa le cose sbaglia e vai tranquillo che
semmai farà qualcosa sicuramente
sbaglierai
ma non per questo non devi farla
è proprio questo il punto il fallimento
va abbracciato come unico mezzo che
abbiamo per comprendere veramente i
nostri errori e migliorare è l'unico
mezzo che ci permette di entrare in
quella cosa che in startup si chiama
feedback loop
il feedback loop è composto da tre step
nel primo step noi Definiamo la nostra
idea di business cioè Decidiamo in che
direzione muoverci
nel secondo step lanciamo nel mercato il
primo prodotto iniziamo a muoverci E nel
99,9% dei casi quando fai startup lanci
il primo prodotto Il prodotto è brutto
funziona male pieno di bug problematico
è normale Anzi è giusto così perché ti
permette di entrare nel terzo step
quello dell'apprendimento cadi ed impari
e noi non siamo bravi se facciamo bene
tutti e tre passi Noi siamo bravi Se
restiamo all'interno di questo loop Se
continuiamo continuiamo e continuiamo a
girare
Quando io ho imparato ad andare in bici
Sono caduto 50 volte però ho imparato
proprio perché non ho smesso di cadere
anzi l'ho accettato quel fallimento
ovviamente non ero consapevole all'epoca
però l'ho accettato è stato l'unico modo
che avevo per imparare quando chiedo
soldi agli investitori prende
un'infinità di porte in faccia
un'infinità
però se mai Qualcuno ha creduto nei miei
progetti è solamente perché non ho
smesso di reiterare questo processo non
ho smesso di farlo per scrivere questo
discorso ne ho cestinati 10 20 Però se
oggi vi sto raccontando cosa penso
dell'equilibrio è proprio perché a forza
di cercarlo ho trovato il modo per
spiegare ciò che penso
non c'è nessuno che ha la ricetta magica
per l'equilibrio nessuno sa qual è
effettivamente il modo per trovarlo
noi non siamo nati per restare immobili
fermi non siamo nati per subire quello
che il contesto esterno ci riserva Noi
siamo nati per cercarcelo l'equilibrio
per direzionare la nostra zona di
movimento
Allora vorrei avvicinarmi alla
conclusione
citando una delle figure che più ha
impattato su di me durante il mio
percorso di studi durante la mia vita da
studente Socrate
Socrate diceva è sapiente solo chi sa di
non sapere
bellissimo Io amo questa frase perché ti
sbatto in faccia la realtà
è sapiente solo chi sa di non sapere
Quindi non sapremo mai ti fa sentire un
granello di sabbia inutile
Nell'immensità dell'universo e Socrate
che era una delle persone più sapienti
del mondo del suo tempo presumeva tutti
i giorni di non conoscere per conoscere
più Questo era il suo modo per stare in
equilibrio era il suo modo per muoversi
E noi invece Spesso siamo dei sofisti la
corrente opposta coloro che presumevano
di conoscere tutto il riconoscibile noi
facciamo la stessa cosa troppo spesso
presumiamo di conoscere il riconoscibile
o di farlo con relativamente pochi
sforzi stando fermi Dove siamo
Ma come dicevo prima il
78,5% degli studenti universitari
italiani almeno una volta nella vita ha
sperimentato Cosa significa non saper
trovare l'equilibrio tra le forze
presenti nella loro vita nella nostra
vita
molti troppi studenti compiono atti
sconsiderati totalmente sconsiderati
perché non riescono a trovare
l'equilibrio lo perdono del tutto
e noi non possiamo
permetterci di essere dei sofisti non
possiamo assolutamente permetterci di
restare fermi Dove siamo
mentre rileggevo il mio discorso mi sono
soffermato su una frase che ho scritto
Forse in un flusso di coscienza quasi
sovrappensiero che però spreme
totalmente l'essenza di quello che oggi
vi sto raccontando del mio discorso
la zona di equilibrio è viva e non
resterà mai ferma immobile Dov'è cresce
se lamentiamo e diminuisce se non
leviamo da mangiare attraverso il
movimento
questo perché è sempre il momento giusto
per iniziare a muoversi è sempre il
momento giusto per iniziare a fare un
qualcosa in più possiamo anzi dobbiamo
sempre tutti i giorni entrare nel nostro
feedback loop
E se io oggi sono qua in veste di
studente a raccontarvi la mia
interpretazione di equilibrio è proprio
perché penso che è oggi il giorno per
imparare ad andare in bici È da oggi che
dobbiamo iniziare a fare un passo in più
a muoverci ad esplorare a cadere e
ripartire e cadere e ripartire di nuovo
è solo così che potremo trovare le
nostre equilibrio Grazie